[Music]  let's just take a moment and try an  exercise pretend I'm Sydney I miss you I  know I probably shouldn't but I think  about you all the time I bet you do  thinking it uh I used to believe that  people determine their own lives yet  there's one force more powerful than  free will  our desires Jane we're just here to  listen at the end of the night we go  into our lives and they leave there's  you're not getting emotionally involved  again are you real  I told you I know well where were you  really you've heard so many boundaries  because I feel like I've been living my  life as two people I don't know which  one is real I don't know who is in  control anymore you need to control your  [ __ ] impulses does it make you feel  powerful to manipulate people like this  I'm afraid our times up  [Music]